you grew up on Walt Disney and you were
fascinated by Walt Disney's animation
techniques and how in the world of
Disney he would come on your television
and explain to you the technology behind
the animation techniques they were using
this was your first inspiration and you
will want it to be in a Disney animator
I I did a lot of drawing I entered
contests I bought books on how to to
draw and how to animate but it didn't
happen you weren't a good draw you know
in the well I actually don't know what I
could have become huh
what I found was that when I went from
high school to college that I realized I
I didn't know how to get to the next
level hmm so below the level I saw were
these phenomenal Disney animators there
were no schools so there was no training
ground so I could measure myself against
where they were and I didn't know the
path to get from one of the other right
so I switched over into physics you see
you go to physics but computers emerge
and somehow you wind up learning about
computer vision and animation was this
at the University of Utah yes you first
were exposed to computers yes so this is
new in the whole field of computer
science at this time ARPA which is
funded by the government was funding
research programs around the United
States with very little bureaucracy and
Utah was picked as a place to do
graphics but it was also picked to be
one of the first four nodes of what
became the Internet
yes ARPANET yes call ARPANET and later
the universities I think they called
bitnet yeah yeah there's something there
but the but the ARPANET was the
foundation and later they just changed
the name when it became big enough but I
was at the one of the first poor nodes
so it we had the internet people there
trying to figure that out we had compute
computer graphics group and a vision
group which is unique in that they were
together working together even though
they're on the same campus on the same
campus it was completely free and open
great professor
but also professors who weren't
micromanaging hmm it's like okay people
we're at the front of the Easter egg
hunt cut the line let's go and this was
a very interesting moment in time
because the United States is a 60s right
the early sixties and the United States
was in a panic over Russia
Sputnik had happened in the government
wanted to have basic research because
they felt technologically we needed an
advantage if we were going to become or
maintain supremacy in the world versus
the Communists vs. the Russians our
driving force behind giving you all the
ability to just freely experiment with
technology the the thing that I loved
about it and is it this in retrospect
yes I grew up with the fear of like oh
the communist threat right but in 57
they launched Sputnik and it scared the
u.s. because they had jumped ahead of us
hmm
and the interesting thing about that is
the response to that fear was to go out
and fund smart people amazing that's an
enlightened response no it's not one
that you hear about today like how and
it's like they did the right thing it's
amazing they said basically we should
just let smart people pursue technology
so we get an advantage as opposed to
going to war blowing that laces up and
they built we built you're still has by
far the greatest a cadet and academic
program system in the world and it comes
out of that mindset post-world War two
and then this was fueled by ARPA and the
whole computer industry is built out of
that that group of people who were who
went to school funded by ARPA and it's
now called DARPA yeah but it was an
amazing period and very formative for me
right oh there were you had some
contemporaries in there who went on to
great things as well
yes there was John Warnock who went on
to form Adobe amazing created the PDF
yeah an auto shop and Photoshop nothing
there was Jim Clark Netscape did
Netscape and Silicon Graphics
we had Alan Kay deter interfaces the
computer interfaces as well as this is
the one he's probably this is more
technical in like in the technical world
but the object-oriented programming
mm you know it's C++ large canal
object-oriented programming came out of
Alan Kay right he was a Utah when I was
there and then went on to to Xerox PARC
so enormously influential people and and
a great group of people to work with